romantisches heidelberg hoch über dem
neckar thront die berühmte schloss wo
ihn am hang des königstuhls gut sichtbar
von der alten brücke in der adventszeit
verwandelt sich die altstadt in einen
riesigen weihnachtsbaum
beliebt bei kindern die eisbahn am
karlsplatz
aufwärmen können sich heidelberger und
touristen mit einem in ganz mitteleuropa
beliebten heißgetränk den glühwein
es ist weihnachten weihnachten im magen
wir mögen dieses getränk und werden es
sicher wieder probieren am marktplatz in
der altstadt schenk christoph schneider
seit über 25 jahren seinen glühwein aus
wenn gerade kein kunde da ist hebt er
den deckel des topfes letzten dampf ab
und lockt so die leute an 17 uhr kommen
die leute nach der arbeit und dann ist
hier trubel und viel spaß angesagt
besonders stolz ist christoph schneider
auf seine neuen merlot glühwein
er ist weniger süß als die herkömmlichen
glühbirne
unsere gäste die sagen selbst wenn mal
drei getrunken haben oder vier kein kopf
am nächsten tag und von diesen
weinbergen kommen die trauben für den
glühwein das weingut adlmüller in reimen
liegt ca 20 autominuten von heidelberg
entfernen
winzer matthias müller bringt glühwein
nicht nur klassisch in rot sondern auch
in weiß und sogar hin auf den markt ganz
traditionell ist der glühwein aus
rotwein gemacht so auch bei uns hier im
hause in den letzten jahren verspüren
wir eine verstärkte nachfrage nach
weißwein weißwein daher da er weniger
gerbstoffe hat leichter ist frucht
betont da ist und in folge dessen war
auch der kundenwunsch einfach nach einem
weißen glühwein in heidelberg haben wir
eine dritte variante einen musik über
ein anlass ist der pink monday einer
benefizveranstaltung zugunsten der
aids-hilfe
wie entsteht der spezielle geschmack des
über 1
natalie müller die mit ihrem mann
zusammen arbeitet ein familiengeheimnis
das rezept nachdem wir heute noch
arbeiten ist ein ganz schlichtes altes
rezept unserer uroma greta was die
zutaten angeht beschränken wir uns auf
drei gewürze nelke sternanis zimt und
beim obst sind es ganz klassisch zitrone
und orange zurück in heidelberg über ein
passt auch gut zu deftigen leckereien
wie reibekuchen und pilzen
glühweinstände gibt es hier viele der
weingenuss gehöre eben zum lebensgefühl
der heidelberger sagt man in der region
mir ist warm und das hält mich auch
warme gefühl angekommen zu sein
sie war ehrlich eigentlich macht über
den geruch aus dem weihnachtsmarkt in
dieser lebten deswegen über heidelberg
eine stadt in der man für die kalte
jahreszeit bestens gewappnet ist